vacation rentals are a hot button issue
in the valley have been for some time
clark county has rules to keep homes
right now anyway from being turned into
party houses these short-term rentals
are not currently allowed in
unincorporated clark county but that
could soon change county is asking for
you to weigh in time is ticking though
bianca holman joining us live to explain
bianca good morning so making money from
vacation rentals well listen up today is
the last day to share your opinion on
how to how the county should regulate
short-term rental properties currently
it prohibits rentals through airbnb and
similar apps for unincorporated clark
county but the state legislature passed
a bill last year that requires the
county to adopt a new policy by july
this year the bill was prompted because
there's a concern that the ban was
ineffective and not uniform now as they
adopt new regulations they want your
input so here's an online survey it asks
what the new ordinance should look like
should the host lose their permit after
certain number of complaints should
there be restrictions on signage should
the county limit the number of permits
and should neighbors this is a big one
be involved in the permit process so the
survey takes about 15 minutes to
complete we do have a link on our
website at 8newsnow.com so definitely go
there to take that survey before the day
ends bianca holman live local now